cero pobreza será posible
cuando yo tenía 21 años hace 6 años
estaba en que la po en una de las
regiones más pobres del planeta este
lugar está en áfrica
ahí conocí a media net
esta niña me cautivó desde el día 1 y se
volvió mi consentida lo que yo no sabía
es que me dan et tenía una maldición una
maldición de nacimiento
tiempo antes su mamá en la desesperación
por el hambre había comenzado a
prostituirse
con el tiempo nace esta niña y su mamá
no entendía por qué enfermaba con tanta
facilidad
resulta ella pensaba que era parte de la
desnutrición que vive en casi todos los
niños de la zona pero resulta que tiempo
atrás cuando ella se prostituía le
transmitieron vih-positivo y ella se lo
pasó a su hija
para hacer el panorama más complicado
estas eran las clínicas locales
esta injusticia y ya estando yo de
regreso aquí en méxico es lo que me
llevó a querer recaudar fondos para
construir una clínica médica en que la
fe
yo quería que niñas como medianet se
pudieran atender en esta clínica
y total empezamos a construir la clínica
y conforme íbamos recaudando los fondos
jamás olvidó que justo cuando íbamos a
terminar de construir la clínica recibo
un mensaje a las 3 de la mañana
recuerdo que cuando yo estaba leyendo
ese mensaje yo sentí que me quitaban el
piso
de esas sensaciones que sientes que se
te hace un nudo en la garganta un
agujero en el estómago
y de repente ya me están saliendo las
lágrimas
resulta que días atrás me dan se había
enfermado
y como ella no tenía las defensas
suficientes y no podía alimentarse
correctamente
ella se a pocas horas había fallecido
yo quería que esa clínica ayudar a niñas
como me dan et
pero principalmente ahmed a net
esta fue la única foto que ahora que
estaba haciendo la presentación pude
encontrar de medan et sonriendo
porque le daba
le da tristeza y pena enseñar sus
dientes carcomidos por la enfermedad que
ella tenía
resulta que números de 25 niños que
nacen con vih en el mundo 18 nacen en
áfrica
y muy seguramente en otra parte del
planeta nace una niña como manet que
también nace con vih
pero que ella sí va a poder llegar a su
juventud y la diferencia es que ella si
se puede alimentar correctamente y tiene
la oportunidad de tener el medicamento
el medicamento que necesita
mientras tanto en lugares como los que
nacen me dan et mamás como la de media
net se preocupan de que le van a dar hoy
de cenar a sus hijos si es que le van a
poder dar algo
la gran diferencia la gran diferencia
que lo cambia todo es el lugar donde
ellas nacieron
la maldición que yo les decía que me
detenía de nacimiento no era el vih
era la pobreza siempre fue la pobreza
analicemos este mapa y lo que podemos
ver es que en lugares como los que nacen
medianet es muy difícil mejorar tu
situación
si naces ahí es muy difícil mejorarla
y esos lugares también los tenemos en
las periferias de nuestras ciudades
aquí hoy haremos alrededor de 100
personas
si los 100 de nosotros imaginemos si los
100 de nosotros hubiéramos nacido en
pobreza en méxico 74 moriríamos en la
misma situación de pobreza
y ahí fue donde entendí que nadie elige
dónde nacer
nadie elige nacer en pobreza simplemente
nacen en ella
y ojo yo no estoy diciendo que las
personas que nacen en pobreza ya no se
deban de esforzar ni que el trabajo duro
no logre desarrollo
lo que estoy diciendo es que cuando
nosotros decimos es que no se esfuerza
quizás estamos pensando en una persona
pero deberíamos de parar y ver a todos
aquellos que sí lo hacen y que trabajan
toda su vida sin descanso y aún así
nacen siendo pobres viven siendo pobres
y mueren siendo pobres
cuando terminamos la clínica médica me
di cuenta que el impacto que habíamos
tenido había sido muy poco profundo
habíamos construir una clínica y si
claro que está ayudando a personas pero
esa clínica no está ayudando a nadie a
salir de la pobreza cuando que se
debería de ser nuestro principal
objetivo
pero porque no lo es
no lo es porque creemos que es demasiado
ambicioso no lo es porque creemos que no
se puede lograr no lo es porque creemos
que es imposible lograrlo
antes era una ofensa a ser mujer
y querer realizar más que las tareas del
hogar
hoy nos escandaliza la idea que se
quiera limitar a alguien solo por el
hecho de ser mujer
antes era un crimen ser homosexual hoy
no se escandaliza la idea de que se
quiera atacar a alguien sólo por su
sexualidad
y qué bueno que no se escandalicen estas
cosas
pero hay algo que ya no nos escandaliza
no nos escandaliza la pobreza
no nos escandaliza ver a un niño en las
calles trabajando
en vez de estar estudiando
no nos escandaliza ver a una familia
vivir en el tejabán en un mismo tejabán
toda la vida se habían dado se habían
parado a pensar que hemos normalizado la
pobreza tenemos la creencia enraizada
que la pobreza es y siempre será parte
de nuestra sociedad
que nos dijo eso
algo que se normaliza no se busca
cambiar
y aquí es donde me hago la gran pregunta
será posible un mundo con cero pobreza
a poco el mundo hubiera invertido tanto
para erradicar el polio para llevar un
nombre a la luna si no lo hubiéramos
creído posible y vaya que son grandes
logros de la humanidad
y no se lograron por sí solos se fijó
una meta ambiciosa se invirtió recurso
se trajo a los expertos a trabajar sobre
el tema y se trabajó en un largo periodo
de prueba y error y no nos detuvimos
hasta conseguir la meta llevar a un
hombre a la luna
lo mismo podemos hacer hoy para
solucionar este problema
pero primero tenemos que creer que ese
problema realmente es viable de
solucionarse
y esto nos debería de interesar a todos
porque además la pobreza es muy costosa
de mantener para nuestras economías
un estudio reciente que se hizo en eeuu
que solo en eeuu se gastan más de 500
mil millones de dólares al año para
mantener la pobreza infantil
esto en términos de mayores gastos en el
sector salud mayores tasas de deserción
y además un aumento significativo en el
crimen
y en cambio se calculó cuánto costaría
erradicar la pobreza en el mundo en todo
el mundo
y era la misma cantidad 7 veces
qué estamos haciendo
estamos haciendo
erradicar la pobreza si se puede y es
necesario
en 1990 el 43% de la población mundial
vivía en pobreza extrema
para el 2020 esta cifra había disminuido
a menos del 9 por ciento
jamás en la historia de la humanidad
había disminuido tanto la pobreza
y menos en tan solo 30 años
y estas noticias tan chingón as no se
lograron por si solas
se luchó para conseguirlo se hicieron
grandes campañas
estrategias globales los países se
comprometieron a invertir en ello
y antes del cobi
la meta mundial establecida por las
naciones unidas era que para el 2030
pudiéramos lograrlo
un mundo con cero pobreza
imagínense
un mundo sin pobreza
después de terminar de construir la
clínica en áfrica en el 2017 pasando los
sismos empezamos a trabajar con la
comunidad de la toma en puebla
no solo en la reconstrucción queríamos
lograr una transformación real
cuando recién llegamos la gente no se
involucraba y no participaba ellos
decían es que eso le toca gobierno yo
soy pobre qué puedo hacer con el tiempo
la gente se empezó a involucrar
allí conocí a doña pancha y a don
faustino una pareja que llegó a la toma
hace mucho tiempo sin dinero y sin
familia
ellos a pesar de que trabajaban de sol a
sol
siempre vivieron al día
y cuando llegaron los sismos
su pequeño tejabán y lo poco que tenían
había quedado destruido se habían
quedado sin nada
me acuerdo que parte de los efectos que
notamos en ellos parte de los efectos de
la pobreza que notamos en ellos era que
cuando llegamos ellos no hablaban y lo
poco que hablaban no se los entendíamos
yo pensaba que hablaban un dialecto y
dos años después me topo frente a esta
escena en donde veo a don faustino con
mariana una voluntaria de cero pobreza y
don faustino le está platicando
anécdotas a mariana le está enseñando un
álbum jamás voy a olvidar esta escena en
donde veo los ojos de don faustino
emocionado porque le está contando una
historia y darse cuenta que mariana se
está riendo porque lo entiende
pensar que dos años antes ni siquiera
hablaban
al otro lado me topo con una escena en
donde está doña pancha en su nuevo hogar
y tiene una cara de orgullo que ese
orgullo se lo da que ella sabe que ella
construyó su propio hogar y no se lo
regalaron don faustino cargo piedras
para su cimentación y doña pancha pintó
sus paredes y lo más bonito fue que toda
la comunidad participó para construir
estos hogares
recuerdo todavía
te doña pancha me dijo llorando
nunca nadie nos había dado tanto cariño
se me pone la piel chinita ahorita
esto este momento jamás lo voy a olvidar
porque fue el momento en el que yo
estuve más cerca de presenciar el cero
pobreza una transformación real
desde que estuve en áfrica me volvió un
apasionado por el tema de la pobreza y
aunque ya la conocí en la práctica desde
entonces no he parado de documentarme
leer e investigar sobre el tema
yo no sólo quería saber lo que ya se
venía haciendo y lo que se planea hacer
lo que yo quería entender era que ya
había funcionado para ponerlo en
práctica
y eso es lo que hemos venido haciendo ya
hay mucha información
y hace tres años terminando la clínica
en áfrica y a la par de la
reconstrucción en puebla empezamos a
trabajar con un sector de mi ciudad en
saltillo un sector el que todos dicen
nombre es el lugar jamás va a
evolucionar nombre es el lugar ya está
acostumbrado a que le regalen cosas y
ese es el típico sector al que todos en
diciembre estamos ahí pero que nomás
pasa diciembre y ya no hay nadie el
resto del año y si yo 14 hace 14 años
estaba un diciembre allí regalando
cobijas y ahora que regresé hace tres
años me topo como si el tiempo nunca
hubiera pasado
el sector estaba igual
mucha cobija mucha despensa pero el
sector estaba igual
para mí ese sector representaba un reto
si nosotros siendo un grupo de chavitos
porque esto fue hace tres años
siendo un grupo de chavitos apasionados
por el tema dirigiendo una organización
civil pequeña al norte de mexico
podíamos lograr que un sector así que
tenía los índices de pobreza en más del
80% pudiéramos lograr que bajaran esos
índices al cero y lograr una
transformación real una comunidad
autónoma
pero pobreza se podría lograr en
cualquier lugar
y así que empezamos empezamos yendo de
casa en casa tocando puertas
empezamos preguntándoles que veían ellos
cuál creían que era su necesidad cómo
creían que la podían solucionar dejamos
de asumir que nosotros teníamos la
solución a sus problemas y empezamos a
escuchar lo que ellos proponían
involucramos a todos
recuerdo que cuando empezamos a trabajar
en este sector no había organización
alguna
solo cinco señoras eran las que
participaban y siempre eran las mismas
cinco
no había pavimento no había electricidad
y por lo mismo había muchísima
inseguridad estaba repleto de tejabanes
los chavos se están uniendo a pandillas
y las niñas se estan embarazando a los
15 años y los niños seguían el camino de
sus mayores un camino de deserción y
pobreza para toda la vida
hoy este sector es otro la comunidad
participa y no solo señoras sino jóvenes
y señores que es lo más difícil que se
involucre
se conformó un comité vecinal que está a
cargo de las madres de familia y ellos
se enfocan en el desarrollo de la
colonia empezaron a desaparecer los
tejabanes y poco a poco veíamos como las
niñas se dejaban de embarazar a los 15
años y estaban estudiando para conseguir
becas los niños ya los jóvenes ya no se
unían a las pandillas y estaban ayudando
a construir hogares de las personas que
lo necesitan en la comunidad
los niños están limpiando y ayudando a
construir casas y ahora saben también de
ahorro
este modelo lo estamos replicando en
otras comunidades de saltillo y también
estamos arrancando en monterrey y en
querétaro
no sé cuánto tiempo nos va a tomar
llevar llegar a cero pobreza en el mundo
llegar a cero pobreza en méxico y no sé
cuánto tiempo nos va a tomar llegar a
cero pobreza en saltillo en monterrey o
en querétaro lo que sí sé es que la
colonia de las ladrilleras que antes
vivía en situación de pobreza el 80 por
ciento de la población está por pasar de
esa cifra a menos del 10 y si seguimos
en este camino muy pronto vamos a llegar
al cero para mí cero pobreza dejó de ser
un sueño y se ha convertido en una
realidad para niñas como me dan et
esto no es sólo una cifra esto lo es
todo
si para llegar a 0 por eso se necesita
un chingo de trabajo de todos pero
primero tenemos que creer que no es solo
un sueño y que es una realidad y hoy te
hago la misma pregunta cero pobreza será
posible gracias